you probably heard that climate
activists great a thumb burg has been
named the time Person of the Year I have
to say I'm frankly appalled outraged by
this this choice because you're telling
me that in the year 2019 2019 the
current year you're naming a privileged
white cisgendered person as your person
of the year Wow Wow Time magazine Wow
very progressive choice reinforced white
heteronormative 'ti some more why don't
you promote promote colonial istic
gender binary paradigm some more while
you're at it push more oppressive
societal constructs just continue with
your insinuations that Western cultures
are more engaged on climate issues while
ignoring the literally millions of
Vietnamese pansexuals gender-fluid
Ethiopians who have been fighting this
fight for thousands of years but none of
them could be named Person of the Year
can they oh no we're just gonna pretend
they don't exist couldn't even find an
intersex Aboriginal gender queer South
Korean none of those available huh oh
they're not doing anything no no it's
all the white people it's all the
privileged white people care about the
planets I am tired of seeing the climate
activism of marginalized communities
erased by the media I'm tired of the
media pretending that people of color
and a gendered people and by gendered
people and try gendered people and
cuatro gendered people don't exist Time
magazine is a white supremacist
publication it should be listed as a
hate group by the government and a Time
magazine in the words of Greta Thune
burg herself I say how dare you how dare
you
how dare you okay
anyway um actually by the way speaking
of woke climate activism I wanted to
have you I don't know if you've seen
this check out this flyer that somebody
posted online it's a picture of well
it's a picture of a flyer for a course
at Portland State University
courtesy of their women it's their women
gender and sexuality Studies department
so you know it's gonna be pretty good
let me see if I could pull it up I just
I just retweeted it on Twitter at Matt
Walsh blog by the way okay here it is so
this is the this is the the flyer for
the course it's queer it's a course on
queer Ecology's queer Ecology's
rethinking the nature of nature and then
it describes the course this class uses
a queer lens to understand bodies places
and the environment we explore how
gender sexuality and queer experience
and identity intersect with race class
disability and settler colonialism to
construct bodies and places as natural
and the role that science plays in
defining nature topics include queer
bodies queering settler colonialism
queer environmental politics disability
and queer environments queering science
queer animals thanks sorry it's very
serious topic I mean the laughs I'm
really just laughing with joy I'm
laughing with with joy finally you know
these sort of subjects are being taught
to our children I mean for too long our
kids have gone to school and learned
about things like science and history
and we have completely neglected to talk
about queer animals queer environmental
Futurity Futurity future youth Futurity
queer environmental Futurity that's a
word that's definitely a word this
to reimagine nature bodies and places
through a queer lens so there you all
I'm going to say is people are going to
pay money for this course people are
going to take this course and pay money
and those same people given that this is
Portland State we're talking about those
same people in a few years are gonna be
unemployed and have massive debt and
they're gonna start crying about their
student debt and and demanding that we
get that we give them debt forgiveness
they're gonna take out their violins and
they're gonna play them and they're
gonna tell us a sad story about how hard
their life is well if you are plunging
yourself into crippling debt for the
sake of this nonsense then you deserve
all of the consequences that come your
way I paid a hundred grand to take
classes on queer ecology and vegan
history now I can't find a job help me
I'm a victim yeah no I don't think I
will help you I
I think of if I were to make a list of
all the people in the world who deserved
help you would literally be at the
bottom of it you would be like number
seven billion on the list
I think we should help every other
person on earth before we help you all
right so our old friend AOC was doing a
bit of grandstanding at a congressional
hearing on Tuesday par for the course
her favorite thing to do and in case in
this case she was grandstanding for
government mandated paid family leave
she wants the government to mandate that
companies give at a minimum she says
three months of paid leave but she
really wants six months nine months 12
months I believe she said mandatory and
in order to make that point she pulled
out a rather tortured analogy do we know
how long
puppies are allowed to stay with their
mothers after a dog has given birth I
don't
eight weeks Wow so the market has
decided that women and people who give
birth deserve less time with their
children than a dog and I think that
that at its core has shown that the
market has failed to treat people with
dignity and with basic respect and so
when that happens I think it's our job
as the public to redefine the rules of
society and to peep and to treat people
who give birth with the dignity that
they deserve thank you very much okay
where do we even begin here first of all
I I honestly don't know where to start I
alright first of all there really isn't
much comparison between dogs and humans
and to compare a human mother to a dog
with a litter of puppies seems rather
dehumanizing to me but the eight-week
thing she's talking about that's the
amount of time that puppies stay with
their mothers until they are shipped off
to another family generally permanently
so we're talking about at eight weeks
they are permanently separated from
their mothers nobody's talking about
permanently separating human mothers
from their children nobody's even
talking about separating mothers for
four days or weeks at a time unless the
unless the human mothers are working for
a company that mines resources from
rocks in the asteroid belt or something
like that and they'll be gone for 50
years but other than that they probably
come home at the end of the day so what
we're talking about his mother's working
for part of the day and then coming home
to their family so it's really not
comparable at all second did you notice
how she said women and people who give
birth so she could just say women who
give birth or really just women you
don't really need the stipulation of who
give birth but should people who give
birth and women to two distinct
categories
she couldn't just say women of course
because that's that this is the sort of
nonsense that leftist political figures
are forced to engage in they don't
believe it themselves even aoc as as as
empty-headed as she sometimes comes
across I can guarantee you that
AOC doesn't really believe that men can
give birth she doesn't really think that
I my theory and I can't prove this of
course but I would be willing to bet
that almost everybody on the left knows
that this gender stuff is crazy they
know that of course men can't give birth
of course your sex is determined by your
by your Anatomy your biology any they
know that they have to know it everybody
knows it I think the number of people
who are really confused on the subject
is very very very small but they all are
pretending and they want us to pretend
also
one of the ways that I know they're
pretending is I have in many many times
I have engaged with these people on this
issue and you find that they just have
no
if you if you try to back them into a
corner to defend the proposition that
anyone besides a woman can have a baby
they can't even begin to defend it and
they won't try they know that it's a
position they cannot at all defend yet
they will continue to say it and and and
that should really why are we even
there's a part of me that thinks we
shouldn't even be engaging like the left
you've just lost everything you have
totally lost every argument now all of
your positions are disqualified because
you are claiming that men can have
babies the moment you say that nothing
else you say I take seriously and I
because either you are arguing in such
bad faith that you are willing to
propose insanity like that knowing that
it's insanity which means I can't talk
to you because you're dishonest or
you're insane I mean those are the two
options you're crazy or you're
pretending to be crazy either way what
is there to talk about I can't talk to
you about anything and this is one of
the this is the problem this is the
divide that exists in our culture these
days that you've got one side of the
political divide living in a fantasy
world just live just may have completely
rejected science biology all of it out
the window and then the third issue here
is I can't help but point out that AOC
is a pro-abortion radical she believes
that it should be legal and is moral to
kill a baby five seconds before it
emerges from the mother's birth canal
the mother's birth canal not the
father's the mother or the father's
birth canal
AOC might say but that's her opinion
that the child can be can be killed at
any point for any reason at any point
for any reason before birth which means
that she has lost the ability to be
taken seriously when she prattles on
about dignity and respect just like she
can't be taken seriously when she talks
about science considering the fact that
she thinks or pretends to think that men
can have babies also when she talks
about dignity and respect for human
beings we can't take that seriously
anyway because because because this is
someone who defends the worst kind of
barbarity so she has lost the moral high
ground fourth thing as for the paid
family leave issue the idea that the
government should require companies to
provide according to Elsi a year of paid
family leave is obviously madness it
just doesn't work so like many liberal
ideas it sounds kind of good at first if
you think about it for only one and a
half seconds so if you spend 1.5 seconds
thinking about it and you don't think at
all about implement implementation cost
effect or anything else then maybe it
sounds good to you if you approach
liberal policies like a word association
game where somebody says a word to you
and then you have to react to it
instinctively without thinking about it
I guess for a lot of people it seems
when they approach liberal policy ideas
that way which is how a lot of people
approach these issues it sounds kind of
good because you say well paid family
leave who could be against that I'm not
against it I think paid family leave is
wonderful but it has to be something
employers work out themselves with their
employees the government cannot mandate
this because think about it if an
employer is required to pay a woman for
12 months to not work
into state or house
the employer is also going to have to
hire a replacement who will have to be
paid
well so so now for a year he's paying
double for that position add in let's
say another woman on on twelve years of
our twelve months of leave why not
twelve years actually let's do twelve
years added another woman on twelve
months of leave and now you've got and
now you've got four times the cost for
two positions
it becomes unsustainable pretty quickly
obviously unsustainable now the only way
that an employer could
make this work maybe is if when the
mother goes on that year of leave he
kind of do whatever she does whatever
her position is he divides it up and
gives it to other people that other
employees and so her position is
absorbed by her duties are absorbed by
other people in the company the issue
with that is well if he does that
and now for a year the company works
fine with other people doing her job
along with their own jobs
then why should he hire her back it
doesn't need her anymore so in in that
12-month period
I either the employer is paying double
which is unsustainable or the woman has
become
at her own job because other people are
doing it and she's not needed either way
it doesn't work here I think is the the
problem when it comes down to it in in
the Industrial Age
we have radically reordered the family
and society we did away with the
traditional arrangement of men being
providers and women being caretakers
that's the way that it worked obviously
in many societies for many thousands of
years but we said no we're not gonna do
that anymore
and now both parents will can be
providers and both can take turns being
caretakers whatever you think of that
shift doesn't matter that's not my point
my point is that there are trade-offs
unavoidable
these trade-offs are inevitable the
trade-off is that one of the trade-offs
anyway is that now with both parents
working and in many situations
I admit that both parents have to work
because that's how we've arranged
society we didn't have to arrange it
this way but we did and so now for a lot
of people it's not a choice it's like
when I talk about the public school
system and I'm a big advocate for
homeschooling I think that that or
private schooling as well depending on
what what private school were talking
about because they're not all good by
any means but and I'm a big critic of
the public school system ideally I think
there shouldn't be a public school
system but many families are in a
position where they have to send their
kid to public school because both
parents have to work they can't afford
private school or there aren't any good
ones in the area and then what are you
gonna do there really isn't any other
option and I fully acknowledge that
admit that but my point is
have setup society in such a way as to
be dependent upon this institution it
doesn't have to be that way and we could
start working in the long term
towards making it so that we're not
dependent on this institution of the
public education we could also in the
long term work to towards a situation
where
you know we don't need to talk about 12
months of paid family leave anymore
those are choices we have to make as a
society as it stands right now
with both parents working
not just babies don't have the same
opportunity to bond with and be raised
by an influence by their parents that's
just how it goes there's no way around
it unless we do a radical reorganizing
of society unless we are looking willing
to look fundamentally at how we approach
families and work these really
foundational things unless we're willing
to look at that and say maybe we're
doing this wrong
if we're not willing to have that
conversation then there's this is just
how it's going to be
folks like AOC they want to have it both
ways they want to say oh yeah women
should go out have a career focus on
that now that that's how what it means
to be empowered is to go out and have a
job and all that while at the same time
insisting that children shouldn't be
deprived of theirs of their mothers
presence in the home well wait a second
how can it be both you can't say both
and why are you I mean if your ice I
joked a minute ago that if you're doing
12 months why not 12 years well really
why not because it's not like a baby's
benefit from having their mothers in the
home for the first 12 months and then
don't benefit anymore that benefit that
you're talking about extends throughout
the entire childhood
so we we have made a choice in this
society that's what I'm trying to that's
the argument I'm making here we have
made a choice the choice that we made
collectively is that you know it's it's
more important to have the parents out
of the house working than it is to have
them
in the house as a constant presence and
we also decided that
other people institutions like the
public school system or babysitter's or
daycare centers can sufficiently
compensate for and fill in for the
parents
that's that's the
that society made that is in fact the
the decision that people like AOC
we'll still defend
while at the same time from the other
direction attacking it so doesn't make
any sense
yes that's not
that's not how I feel
I'm not really on board with with this
but that's the way it is now
and I don't think you can fix it just by
mandating some policy and then there's
this the most overrated athlete in
America also the most unlikable Megan
Rapp you know one person of the she won
sports Person of the Year from Sports
Illustrated this week I think it should
have been Lamar Jackson that one
personally now I'm I'm a homer I'm a
Baltimore guy so I'm biased I think
Lamar Jackson is is not only changing
the game of football not only is he the
the story of the year in American sports
just electric electric athlete a lot of
fun to watch but he's also just a really
likable guy he's a great role model he
does all of his press conferences after
the game he shows up wearing a t-shirt
that says nobody cares work harder
that's that's just the best message you
could hope to get from somebody in a
position like that and he lives it - he
doesn't doesn't complain doesn't make
things about himself he's kind of the
he's kind of the anti Kaepernick in a
lot of ways I don't mean that in a
political sense I don't know what his
politics are doesn't talk about them
which i think is great but just in the
sense of he's not making it about
himself he's not complaining lifts his
teammates up all the time I just I think
it's a great I think he's a great role
model for kids and he should have been
the sports Person of the Year but no we
didn't give it to him we gave it to in
many ways his diametric opposite
megyn rap you know but during her her
acceptance speech she blasted Sports
Illustrated for not being diverse enough
watch and while we don't get to choose
what it is that we witness we are the
gatekeepers of those stories and we do
get to decide how we bear witness to the
world around us and to the truth that we
see is it true that I am the fourth
woman deserving of this award
[Music]
is it true that's so few writers of
color deserve to be featured in this
publication is it true that so few
women's voices deserve to be heard and
deserve to be read in this publication I
don't think so
so there you go and I have nothing to
say about that other other than to laugh
at it
this is what you get you know Sports
Illustrated they've gone above and
beyond to appeal to the whoa crowd
they've done everything they can to woke
up I and it's never enough
never ever enough this is the lesson we
learn over and over again it's never
enough
you can that they are giving her an
award and she's still upset at them
she's still mad still somehow persecuted
but so there's
that's why really I just I don't there
are some I think Lamar Jackson very easy
to root for someone like Megan rap you
know going around complaining constant
complaining about her money that's the
worst thing to complain she's a rich
athlete going around complaining she's
not paid enough when in reality she's
actually overpaid all this stuff about
the witness but soccer women's soccer
stars aren't paid enough or underpaid
compared to the men that when you look
at how much money they bring in in
comparison how much money they make they
are actually overpaid and they make a
lot of money Megan Rapinoe is a rich
rich woman still complains about it
though so this is someone who's just
impossible to root for I don't know how
you do it alright let's go to emails
Matt well show at gmail.com
Mata's is from Marina says Matt why do
you have just one stocking on the mantel
behind you it's kind of depressing I do
have just one stocking I don't think
there's anything depressing about it's
actually a really fun tradition in my
house the tradition is I'm the only one
who gets a stocking for Christmas I'm
also the only one who gets presents on
Christmas or at any other time of the
year so everyone has a chance to really
go out have a great time buying me
presents and and the good thing is that
everyone in the family learns about the
value of giving now I've already learned
that value so I don't need to learn
anymore so I don't need to give but
everyone else needs to learn so they go
and they buy me present and then and
then it's it's very sweet on Christmas
morning you know the kids rush down
everyone rushes down you know it's like
classic Christmas everyone rushes down
into the living room and then they form
a circle I sit in the middle of circle
and unwrap all my presents usually takes
about three hours and the kids are just
crying tears of joy the whole time it's
really a wonderful wonderful tradition
this is from Hunter says hey Matt I've
been watching your show for a few months
now and although I enjoy the show I'm
decidedly more liberal than you on the
topic of abortion
you seem very firm in your beliefs that
is an act of evil yes I would say I am
over the months of watching the show
this has been one of the handful of
issues that you haven't been able to
sway my position my opinion on there are
two points that always come up to me
come to mind when thinking about your
argument one what if I were to get a my
girlfriend pregnant I'm nineteen working
on my education my girlfriend
is getting ready to ship out its
airforce basic training in January a
baby is not a part of our short-term
plans and would undoubtedly destroy both
of our plans for life this makes this
must be a concern for many young people
and it is a very real fear despite
taking the proper precautions I know
this is not an excuse for evil but I
would not be able to put my personal
feelings aside and neither would my
girlfriend if I came down to abortion -
putting aside my own personal feelings
when looking at abortion from a
statistical point of view is it possible
that abortion would help a society
overall by limiting the number of single
mother mothers and the amount of crimes
so on and so forth if this was proven to
be true could abortion be looked at
through the lens of a necessary evil
such as war or allowing aoc supporters
to vote well done I you know but I don't
consider that to be a necessary evil
actually I would love to hear back from
you privately or at the end of your show
keep up the good work well you say that
I haven't been able to sway you on
abortion I consider that a huge failure
in my part considering I talk about it
so often so let me see if I can let me
see what I can do here you give you give
your - sticking points one is you you
feel like you might need you might need
to have an abortion quota court need to
have that option open to you because the
baby would destroy your plans and life
you say and number two you say that it's
a necessary evil because it cuts down on
single motherhood crime poverty etc well
I feel like I probably don't need to
argue against your first point that's
not so much an argument from you but
just you being honest about your
motivations I appreciate the honesty I
think I probably don't need to tell you
in fact I know I don't need to tell you
because you say yourself that it's not
an excuse for evil well it's not that's
the answer it's exactly right see what
we're trying to figure out is not
whether abortion might be useful I
concede that it could be so if that's
the discussion is it useful I say sure
lots of things could be useful if they
were to legalize bank robbery that could
be very useful to me if I'm in a pinch
and I don't have any money
I can go rob a bank now it's not so
useful to the people who get their money
stolen or to the bank or the people who
maybe get harmed during my armed robbery
not so useful to them but to me
selfishly yeah very useful carjacking is
a useful option if you don't have a car
but don't want to go
pay for one at the used car dealership
you just steal somebody else's useful
for you not so useful for the person who
gets their car stolen murder can be
useful to iknow it can be a very useful
tool
think about how useful it is for the mob
when they murder witnesses okay how
useful it is for drug gangs when they
kill off the competition it's a very
useful thing the question though is not
whether it is useful but whether it is
objectively right or not also by the way
babies don't destroy your plans in life
they might require an adjustment but
there's no reason why I have to destroy
all your plans I have four kids now I'm
married and I'm older but I have four
kids I haven't abandoned my goals or my
dreams or my plans in life at all in
fact I I feel even more motivated to
pursue my my goals because I have kids
there have been chances that I've taken
there I've been risks that I've taken
Gamble's that I've made smart Gamble's
and they turned out to be calculated
Gamble's that I have made in pursuit of
my goals that I maybe would not have
made if I if I didn't have kids but it's
my one of my main motivations is to
provide for them to provide a life for
them and to provide for them in life and
so so it all depends on your perspective
you could look at having a baby as oh my
gosh my life is over
or you could look at it as this is a new
life that has come into existence my
life has gotten more interesting maybe
they're gonna be more challenges but
it's also it's also more fulfilling now
and I've got more motivation more reason
to work harder but let's move on to your
actual argument you say is it possible
that abortion could help a society
overall by limiting the number of single
mothers and the amount of crime and so
on and so forth if this was proven to be
true could abortion be looked at through
the lens of a necessary evil there's a
major flaw in your look your your
argument hunter and maybe maybe by
pointing this out maybe it'll slice way
you a little you'll have to let me know
the flaw is this mmm
you just said would just as much justify
killing infants and toddlers as it would
killing the unborn
so let me ask you this would you support
a campaign encouraging poor single
mothers to murder their two and
three-year-old children what would you
think if suddenly across the country
mothers were taking their toddlers into
bath tubs and drowning them legally now
this would undoubtedly help the mothers
financially also let's face it some of
those babies are gonna grow up and
become criminals some of them are gonna
grow up and end up on the welfare system
you know and so we've dealt with that
problem by killing them of course some
of them may also have grown up to be
philanthropists and teachers and
surgeons and doctors and soup kitchens
volunteers and so you've wiped all them
out too but certainly there are going to
be some future criminals in that bunch
as there would be in any random group of
children but what would you say about
that again it is justified using the
exact same argument you just made
exact same situation it's not like this
is unprecedented either infanticide has
been practiced in many cultures
throughout the world and throughout
history so what would you say I'm
guessing you would be horrified and why
because you realize that these pragmatic
considerations could not possibly ever
ever ever justify the mass murder of
innocent children and further you
realize that any societal gains made
through efforts like that are not even
close to being worth the cost you
realize that if killing toddlers helped
us become a richer Society that would
not be a compensation for the fact that
we have forfeited our souls we are a
richer Society but also a very evil one
and you realize that if all of this
death and bloodshed would make us
wealthier as a society and more
comfortable then in that case it would
be better to be poorer and less
comfortable
so when you look at this situation I'm
assuming you would say
um that if this is the only way
masu mning you would say you would
rather be a poor country that doesn't
kill toddlers then a rich one that does
and if I'm right about how you would
feel about two and three year old
children being drowned in the bathtub in
Mass then all I'm asking you is to take
that logic and apply it to the unborn
and then you see how your your argument
though pragmatic and practical is
totally off-base
it completely ignores
the moral consideration here which we
cannot ignore and if we get to a point
where we're saying the only thing that
matters is whether or not this might
practically help some group of people
that's what we're saying then we have
just invited in all manner of the worst
kinds of evil you could ever imagine
thank you for
the email though and thanks for
listening and keeping an open mind as
they say this is from Joe says dear
mighty and powerful leader I recently
started working at an office with an
open floor plan and low walled cubicles
yesterday a co-worker microwaved canned
tuna for lunch the stench permeated
through a large portion of the floor and
lingered for 10 to 15 minutes I searched
my immediate surrounding area in order
to hopefully hand down a swift
punishment but found nobody eating the
tuna
therefore the smell came from outside a
10-foot parameter or made its way all
the way through a break room 50 feet
away under your regime how would this
individual be punished for this vile
assault on my olfactory nerves my first
thought is a twisted version of I for an
eye and they'd be stoned to death with
cans of tuna but I would like to know
your official ruling I have so many
questions Joe who microwaves tuna first
of all that's just egregious bringing
tuna to work in the first place is
unacceptable but something microwave
that's like it's it's like if someone
took their shoes off on a plane which is
bad enough but then stuck their their
smelly disgusting hairy feet right under
your air vent overhead so that the the
stench is wafting directly into your
nostrils that's the kind of thing of a
person does that on a plane the air
marshals gonna arrest them and throw
them out of the plane at 35,000 feet I'm
pretty sure that's the law what I would
say with your suggests and you say
stoning them to death with tuna cans I
find that pretty inappropriate and
shocking honestly that you would suggest
that because the cans aren't going to be
hard enough I think to actually bludgeon
someone to death so what I would suggest
this might be a little impractical my my
penalty I think would be bring them out
to the ocean find it you know capture a
real tuna fish those things are pretty
big buying them to the tuna fish and
then let the tuna fish drag them into
the dark depths of the ocean that that's
my first thought you know about how we
would handle that but certainly some
practical concerns there I think as a
matter of justice that would certainly
be the most just way to deal with that
I'm sorry you had that you had to be
assaulted in that way at your place of
work and then we've got
a bunch of other emails but I think you
know we're gonna wrap it up there and
maybe I'll save some of these other
emails for tomorrow again Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt well show at
gmail.com thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Sean Hampton executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Sterling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Donovan Fowler audio mixer Mike
core Mina the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]